this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happened you bad
[__] it's Thursday December the
1st the joint is brought to you by
steps.com listen it's not too late to
get your holiday mailing and shipping
under control sign up now and you'll be
printing your own postage in minutes you
know how easystamps.com is [__] easy
you print the label you weigh the Box
you put the label on the box you put it
on your mailbox and the post off man
comes and gets it how easy is that use
stamps.com to print postage whenever you
do business all you need is a computer
and a printer with stamps.com you can
easily schedule pickup and compare
carriers and rates with the click of a
button if you're running an online store
that's where stamp.com lines it works
seamlessly with all major shopping carts
and marketplaces listen the holiday
season is upon us trade late nights for
silent nights and get started with
stamps.com today sign up with the promo
code Joey j-o-e-y for a special offer
that includes a four-week trial free
postage and digital scale I don't care
if you got a big business or a small
business stamps.com will work for you
I've been with them for over 10 years
they got no long-term commitments no
contracts just go to stamps.com Click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter code Joey and your Tip Top
Magoo stamps.com
at the code Joey the joint is also
brought to you by c b d lion when it
comes to CBD the lion is the best they
ran a tremendous Black Friday sale with
40 off last week they still got a sale
going on Delta eights the [__] Gummy
Bears the cream the kinesiology tape the
bat balls
I mean listen CBD line has it all go
read that third party lab results and
get back to me [__] stop buying
[__] CBD at the liquor store they
don't sell CBD at a liquor store CBD
lion pressing code Joey or joint now
let's get this [__] party started on
a beautiful
[__] Thursday morning
[Music]
Jack one two welcome to Uncle Joey's Joy
what's happening you bad [__]
it's Thursday the 1st of December the
rent is due in a big [__] way
and it's like one of those rent checks
that you don't want to pay you're like
[__] I ain't gonna pay December
because I need money for [__] the
holidays and snacks and a new outfit for
Grandma's house and [__] but you gotta
do it but the bad news is it's [__]
December good news for a guy like me
it's bad news for a lot of people I mean
this is the time of the year man when uh
you could see people going to a [__]
coma
or they [__] blow the [__] up you
know
either you know this I I go down my
block at night there's a house down the
block the Pumas I love them
the [__] house is gorgeous it's
[__] gorgeous they have put lights
and arrows and [__] Santa Clauses
sled lights it is [__] gorgeous and
you look at it and it inspires you like
you're like that's [__] great how
come I was never like one of those guys
that [__] Christmas Comes I'm outside
[__] throwing lights I helped my wife
the other day for about 15 minutes we
threw up some Puerto Rican lights and
[__] but it's not like uh I was never
really Overjoyed about Christmas like I
had one Christmas that I remember that
was [__] phenomenal I don't know how
my mom pulled it off you know it's that
Christmas that you're like
one of your friends pulls you aside one
of those little [__] and go you
know what are you getting for Christmas
or whatever the [__] and you're like you
know what did your parents bring you and
you're like parents it's Santa and you
know because you're a [__] Santa
believe but still and they're like nah
your parents bring you gifts and you're
[__] confused for a few days you
don't want to ask nobody because you
don't want to look like an [__]
but you're kind of confused you go you
know what I'm gonna keep my eye on it
this year a little bit so this year you
watch all your mom's movements you look
in the closet you look for gifts it was
one of those years where I think that
[__] my mother knew I was on the
walk path for Christmas to find out the
[__] and she took me to the bar in
Jersey
I don't know how the [__] she did it
because I was with her
we left I mean we left at like seven
o'clock for Jersey we were living in New
York City obviously 205 West 88th and we
left at like seven and the whole night
she was at the [__] bar I watched her
I didn't take a nap I didn't do nothing
I stuck through it like [__] glue at
three in the morning we got in the car
we went back to New York and when I
walked in the house the place looked
like [__] my neighbor's house there
was lights and Gifts everywhere and
[__] cookies for Santa and not even
real like chocolate chip cookies they in
Cuba they put like [__] crackers
Cuban crackers with a piece of guayaba
so we left [__] Santa some Cuban
snacks and I was blown the [__] away I
didn't know how the [__] they pulled it
off but
I was okay with it and after that I was
like [__] I don't even care if it's
Santa or not I had a good Christmas and
that was probably you know after that
like
it just it's just so [__] my house
was simple like what do you want for
Christmas nothing Mom what do you want
for Christmas and you went to a store
and you got it for them there's no
surprise there was no [__] [__] going
up in the air and then my mother died
and then Christmas became
something else you know the first five
years after you lose somebody uh special
in your life the holidays aren't the
same especially if they went nuts on
[__] Thanksgiving or they went nuts
on Christmas you missed that [__] for
[__] ever
when uh after my mom died you know I
looked at the Benders I looked at the
runnies
and they tried to make Christmas you
know Christmas but
it wasn't working for Uncle Joey that
[__] was not gonna work for me singing
fake Christmas songs my mother's [__]
dead what is that is saying Jingle Bells
about
but through the years you know you get a
little better I always got depressed I
mean the year I was [__] homeless 84.
that was a rough [__] Christmas that
was like one of those Christmases that
you like
God if this is Christmas I can't wait to
bump into hell because this is hell this
was hell you know and
some people try to make your Christmas
holiday great you know some people
really try to invite you over and feed
you and they'll give you like a gift
that was intended for their grandparents
they'll give it to you to make you feel
good like a green wallet or a [__]
t-shirt or something and and it works it
all [__] works you know but the thing
about Christmas is you letting you go
into a funk I know for a fact I would
let myself go into a funk and the more I
got closer to Christmas I would snort
more and drink more and drink more and
snort more that's how I could tell you
know without even knowing
I just went from getting high three
nights to maybe four [__] nights five
nights to ease the pain but don't ever
fall don't ever feel down over the
holidays it ain't [__] worth it man I
had so many
painful [__] Christmases and I tell
you it's like every other [__]
Christmas means nothing to me since I've
had mercy
Christmas is a [__] great I mean when
you have a kid around you know it picks
it up a little bit California
Christmases sucked because there was no
snow
there was no snow I'm trying to [__]
jump up and down and sing Jingle Bells
and I'm sweating after death because
it's [__] 70 degrees out so it's
[__] cold here and it's cold already
it's December [__] first and it's
cold already not really cold I mean I
don't know when we're gonna get snow or
whatever but that's not the [__]
point
it's where you let
your [__] mind go I mean
the Christmas that I was homeless I just
kept
I would sit there in this [__] rocket
ship at night and just think about
you know how could God I mean listen
your life sucks year round right like
you know I don't care if my life sucks
[__] from January 1st
to December 23rd as long as
you know you feel better for Christmas I
mean and and it's tough when you when
you have a [__] life you can't put
nothing together
you can't put money together for a great
gift I mean you put you put a couple
gifts together you buy your mom a gift
and your girlfriend a gift
but we always feel so [__] inferior
this time of the year that's
that's what I remember the mo if I have
to put a word on it what I felt from
November [__] 26th to December 26th
you just feel [__] like you're not
worth it that's how I always felt so I
know if I felt I feel this way all the
time no but I always felt like uh
I I don't know like I wasn't cut out for
Christmas you feel like you don't have
no [__] money your Christmas ain't
gonna be great and
the end of this [__] like now at my age
I gotta be honest with you guys
Christmas is not about money
it's not about money we
As Americans have let ourselves go there
and we put some extra pressure on
ourselves Christmas is about love Chris
is about looking at people and I love
you let's spend some time together you
know let's drink some [__] eggnog
let's put some rum in it you ain't got
run up with Jack in it Christmas is
about making it work for years I gave up
on Christmas like I would just go to
Christmas season I'm gonna just give up
now it's going to be a miserable
Christmas that was I did that for about
15 [__] years and then that got old
there was a time on Christmas and
Thanksgiving I didn't want to go to
anybody's houses how [__] bad is that
you have any [__] thanksgivings I
spent alone with Boston [__]
Market that sliced white turkey [__]
from Boston Market that's when Boston
Market was good in Seattle I spent a
couple [__] uh New Years alone not
New Year's Christmases I spent a couple
thanksgivings alone you know
Christmas without a girlfriend when
you're 20 or 21 oh
oh that's brutal
just having Christmas and going to a
couple's house and that kissing and
hugging in front of you and you're
kissing the [__] dog the dog's height
the dog's dry humping your leg over
[__] the holidays that's the most I
mean all that [__] sucks because you
think about it because you let it suck
like I did for years and then one day I
just snapped out of it I think like
94 93 I had a shitty Christmas
all those Christmases were [__]
shitty but 94
it was just like I I still remember
every individual Christmas whether I had
money or not how I felt whether I was
able to eat I mean Last Christmas I had
[__] coverage so I got a pass last
year
but all the Christmases before like ever
since I've had mercy yeah
it's helped it's helped going to see
Santa which She [__] hates
she doesn't want to see Santa at all I
got like four pictures of with Santa and
she's five feet away from the
[__] she refuses to take a
picture with Santa I don't know why I
don't know but Santa molester in a
previous life she just does not like
[__] Santa so
I'm serious I don't know what I said
she's three so she's three we took her
to Universal
one year she was like two we put her on
the lap get me off the [__] lap she
threw a pacifier and she just does not
like the [__] so
this year she's gonna she wrote him a
letter and she's been asking me every
day Dad
didn't get back to me on that [__] yeah
you know and that's what makes it fun
again like dealing with a kid thinking
if they're not gonna get a gift and [__]
and you're looking at him going what you
know
listen this it's taken me a long time to
get a
you know adjusted since I moved here it
took me a lot longer than the [__]
girls they were often running like
[__] uh that guy when he got out of
prison The Sopranos and they broke the
guy's arm a week later my daughter and
my [__] wife got off and [__]
running I've had some hiccups here and
there but it's getting smoother every
goddamn day
last night against my best wishes
there's a kid at Jiu Jitsu great kid
Alex
Alex yeah Alex's name and we were
talking one night a couple weeks ago I
went to Jujitsu at night
and I was telling that my daughter came
up to me one day we're just talking
about
[__] and she goes dad you know
I like throwing punches at Jujitsu and
stuff like that I mean it blew my mind
the conversation she's like but
you know I really want to wrestle
and I'm like come again you want to what
and she goes I really want to wrestle
you know I wrestle with my friends and I
do pretty good I use some Jujitsu stuff
but then I get him down and I go who the
[__] thought you had to wrestle
and she goes Mateo and those guys always
wrestle and we go over there the girls
like okay you know whatever and I just
yesterday that like
all right you want to wrestle you know
and then I know there's a bartender at
cousins owns a wrestling school
so I contacted them they was like the
girls are like 14 you know you can bring
her in
but it's not going to be fair you know
so I didn't know what to think and then
a couple weeks ago at night I went to
jiu jitsu
and I was talking to this guy and he
goes you know my daughter I can't come
on Tuesdays and Thursdays starting next
week because my daughter wrestled and I
go what your daughter wrestles and she
goes yeah she comes here too she's nine
and she wrestles I go yeah I said they
were doing a program at the wreck
for kids and he goes ah I coached the
[__] team
and I always want to bring my daughter
down and my wife wouldn't allow it
because she's got basketball on this and
that and he goes bring it down you know
so I asked I go you want to go down
there and see one of these classes and
she's like yeah
I thought she would forget about it holy
[__] she had bugged me every day Dad
when are we going to the wrestling class
Dad when are we going to wrestling class
dad when we going to wrestling class
guys
listen I put my daughter in MMA
because I got in there with a lunch box
when I was a kid and I didn't know what
to do and that was the worst feeling in
the [__] world is getting hit in the
head with a lunch box and not knowing
what the [__] to do I was six I was lost
I just ran and cried I didn't know what
to do I was passing out from the blood
but that [__] always stuck with me all
right and then I realized as I got a
couple years went by you know I faint
when I see blood I [__]
[__] is it if there's too much movement
around me I don't like it you know I
just get in the 70s you didn't know what
anxiety was
you just knew something wasn't [__]
right
and when the action got too much I
always had to sit away and put a towel
over my head to calm down a little bit I
didn't [__] know so
I joined martial arts as a kid because
of Bruce Lee thank God for that
[__] and I pursued it till maybe
I was 16 and I didn't turn out a tough
guy I didn't turn out great form or any
of that [__] I just you know you know
how to get hit you know how to cover
yourself and you know how to breathe
yourself out of the situation
you know fear you know you get hey you
don't know what the [__] going on
you know when I got hit by that lunchbox
I was a kid it's not like I was 24 and
got hit you know how to I just did not
know what to do I knew how to put my
hands up and I knew how to defend myself
and my mom put me in karate and that's
not the point the point is I didn't want
that to happen for her
you know MMA is great for a kid you know
whatever [__] jiu jitsu's great for a
kid boxing is great they're all great
anything that you put your kid in just
so he gets along with little kids you
don't want to put them in there to be a
world champion there's a guy great guy
great guy
and his son is a [__] great kid good
looking polite is good at softball I've
seen him play different things you know
but he goes to Fat Joe's
with me and my daughter that's where she
goes for jiu jitsu and Emma Maine [__]
and the kids is good at what he does you
know he's good at takedowns and a couple
of arm bars and throwing kicks and
punches but you could tell this is not
the kids thing
you know when I take Mercy to this it's
not I don't want her to be a [__]
martial let me get the wrong I don't
want her to be a fighter
but I'd like for her to pick up a couple
martial art things like respect
discipline you know getting up and
forcing yourself to do push-ups whatever
the [__] martial arts offers you you
know
that's the reason why I put her in there
was no future in her being in the UFC do
you want to see your [__] kid or your
brother or sister you know when I see
like uh a fighter that
maybe I'm an acquaintance of him it's
like we talk on the phone or nothing
like that one like Mickey Gall Mickey
gall's my dear friend he's starting a
podcast by the way Mickey gall's a great
guy you know when I watch Mickey golf
fight and he loses even if he doesn't
get knocked out it affects me guys it
bothers the [__] out of me that's my
friend getting [__] hit you know I
would never watch Anderson Silva fights
after I met him I liked him I liked the
guy so I just like I don't really want
to watch his [__] fights you know
when I like somebody I don't want to see
them I don't even forget when John Fitch
for GSB 10 years ago it was a battle and
a half and I was there with Ari and
Duncan and Joe you know
but I'll never forget
John Fitch walking to the ambulance
and me sitting outside the ambulance and
I was [__] crying
I was [__] crying I'm a grown man and
I'm crying for John Fitch I mean he's
bloody you know GSP was beat up too he
was in the other ambulance but he's my
friend I like this guy
it [__] killed me like it was like I
don't know I can't deal with this [__]
so if that's how it affects me with my
friends
how do you think it affects me with my
son Mike's son if Mike told me his son
was an MMA fighter and I went down to
see him and I became friends with the
kid and he gets punched in the head and
bloods everywhere I'm not gonna [__]
feel too good about it you know nobody
is it's a part of fighting and I get it
you get stitched up and your back like
herpes but still nobody wants to see
your your sons or daughters blood
[__] [__] up so for me this wasn't
an option it's not like I was like yeah
go get in there do the arms my dog when
I go in there when I went to Fat Joe's
two days ago with a
all those [__] kids were doing [__]
wrong all of them were doing the [__]
even my daughter she does the throw she
likes strong people but the neon belly
to arm bar she has a problem with it
that's not what it's about
when I you know how many times I'll ask
my daughter on a Monday Mercy you want
to go to [__] fat Joe's and she'll go
not to that then the next day I'll say
something like you want to go to fat
Joe's
and she'll go yeah okay you know and I'm
like what
listen as soon as we walk in that
[__] door of fat Joe's
there's a huge smile on the face she
she's with friends you know many times
she's told me that I got friends at
school I got friends of softball and I
got friends with Fat Joe she's got a
friend Joey over there and Athena and
she's got some kid with big ears neck
and they Giggle and they laugh and they
throw each other do you think I give a
[__] if the throw's wrong or not or if
she's executing she's [__] nine what
do I give a [__] about that I just
wanted to laugh when you're a dad and
when you're a friend to somebody and
they're laughing you just want to see
them [__] laugh you know
so whenever I talk to this dad he's
always like I don't know my son and I'm
like listen this is one of the many
things he does when you're a child what
didn't you [__] do as a kid I had a
comic book collection I played the bass
I played baseball if you [__]
think he had jobs [__]
I was a GI Joe guy I bought a [__]
nobody remembers the story I told when I
bought the Barbie house and snuck her in
and my mother almost killed me
then I had the GI Joe's [__] the
Barbies and [__] you you know I've done
it all as a kid I was an only child
so I was [__] for what the [__]
would I learn from that
kids are going to try listen you're not
there's a there's a guy online this
kid's a drummer he's like a six-year-old
drummer
the drums are like twenty thousand
dollar drums
no no but they're like top of the line
he got them custom made and [__] because
I read the article he put up by the sun
and the twenty thousand dollars with
twenty thousand dollar pair of drums
make your son a better drummer
for me
so when your kids trying [__] like
yesterday I went I I took it to the
[__] wrestling thing finally she kept
asking me that it's Tuesday you're gonna
take me to wrestling that it's Tuesday
you're gonna take me I said finally I
had I read out an option so
I was like listen I'm gonna walk in
there with her and when she sees these
kids jumping up and down and getting
thrown up in the air she's gonna go Dad
the same for me you're right and then
we'll go home and nobody's feelings got
hurt right
[__] no
we walked the first we went to the wreck
and it wasn't there so I'm like [__]
am I I'm off the hook and she's like
it's okay Dad but I could tell she was
upset so I asked the lady at the wreck
where's the [__] uh
what's the [__] uh you know the
wrestling practice she goes you got to
go to Middle School
so I drove over to the middle school and
sure enough that's 200 Cars I'm like
[__]
this is the place and so I go I pull up
and I go open the back door of the gym
mercy and tell me what you see she came
back like that there's a bunch of boys
wrestling that I go is any girl she goes
I didn't see them I go [__] but let's go
in there I thought she was gonna go no
there's boys [__] no she slammed that
[__] car door walked in there with me
we walked in I saw some friends of mine
I know like the kids go to either
softball or fat Joe's with Mercy we
walked in I saw a few parents and [__] I
sat her down she was like her eyes were
huge they had like an advanced class in
front of her and kids her age over on
another map but the advanced class they
were all 12 year old kids [__] like that
she was watching the moves and I could
see her [__] eyes like she was like
lighting up like oh [__] God damn it
then the coach came over Alex and he's
like hey Joey how are you did you bring
your daughter I'm like yeah he goes does
she want to go in I go Mercy you want to
go in and I was praying that she goes
nah not today I just want to look she
was like yeah I'm like oh no next thing
you know her jacket was off shoes were
off she's on a mat with the
nine-year-old girl they're throwing each
other around he was just teaching the
basics but then she made her wrestle the
coach made her wrestle with a little boy
and the little boy [__] through Mercy
I go oh this is not gonna be good I saw
Mercy scramble and grab the [__] kid
the guillotine and push him around I'm
like oh
when we got back in that car
she didn't shut the [__] up till we got
home do you understand me she didn't
shut the [__] up until we got home and
then when I walked in the door she ran
in the [__] house ran upstairs I
could hear her downstairs because when I
walk in I'm you know taking off my
jacket I'm settling down I could hear
her up there [__] yelling at the mom
I loved it and she's like Mom we got
something to tell you she's like I can't
tell you but dad's gonna tell you
what is it and she's like I joined
wrestling
and my wife is like
I don't know where this is coming from
you know she's a mom too
but I go you know what Tyree she was
dead one of the girls from the softball
team was there and she was pissed
because she couldn't sign up
so I was like even Amelia was [__]
pissed he was dead she was like well all
right I'll let it sign up so
I don't want my daughter to be some
[__] wrestler and get choked the [__]
out but
if you would have seen her [__] smile
on that mat
and that's all that matters I don't give
up she got they got wrestling meets
the first one is December 15th in 14
[__] days she has to wrestle
and I'm like how the [__] is she gonna
pull this off you know what guys they're
kids
she went to jiu jitsu she went to MMA
for [__] 45 minutes and then after that
came home I had a snack I went to
wrestling practice for damn near two
[__] hours
running around push-ups jumping jacks
she came in last night like nothing
[__] happened
you know and I had my apprehensions like
I don't know I don't want to do [__]
this [__] but this is what she wants to
do so
yeah she got basketball tonight
wrestling two days MMA today softball
starts in January
but you know what you want to keep them
active and that's the whole [__] deal
there you know
and now I got something to do with her
during the holidays it's something nice
to do practices at 6 30 to 8 at night so
it gets me out of the [__] house
obviously I'm gonna sit there and talk
to a couple parents a couple of moms
there was a mom sitting next to me she's
like I know you I don't know you don't
she goes yes I do I go no no I never met
you before because I saw you in Point
Pleasant one night cracking dirty jokes
oh yeah that's me we started talking
[__]
but yeah this is the adventures of being
a [__] dad I can't believe how much
how much my life has changed guys I I
cannot even believe the [__] that used
to get my dick hard doesn't even [__]
impress me anymore I don't want to do
any of it I don't want to do [__] any
of it like I said today I got an
audition for a voiceover and I'm excited
about that because you don't have to do
much with a voiceover just put it on
your tape recorder and [__] it and
[__] send it and then when you do the
job some jobs don't even want you to
come in
you got a microphone they'll they'll
Zoom with you and tell you how they want
the line and it's [__] easy as [__]
man but now I was thinking about all the
Christmases
and it really like you know
I'm 60.
if I had
[__]
15 good Christmases
15 good Christmases and it had to do
with me it had to do with me being a
junkie me not having parents me just you
know
now I love [__] Christmas I mean I'm
not dressing up like Santa hat and I'm
not jumping up and down and doing all
this [__] but you enjoy it a little bit
more
because it hits close to home you're
making somebody [__] happy you know
I think about that last Christmas and
Boulder that was
whenever I think of Christmases that's
the Christmas I go wow
you know
my life used to be [__] and I try to
tell people all the time
my life used to be so hand to mouth
it's it was crazy
Mike I wish
you know when I started comedy after I
got divorced I mean I
I struggled financially until I was
about 25 24 and then I started making a
little bit of money
you know money that you could put away
money like save money as a Salesman and
[__] like that
and then you know I put away a ton of
money uh
after I came out of prison I had like
three [__] jobs I roofed I [__]
worked at a comedy club and my whole
goal was to bank [__] money like I
had never banked money before the money
I did Bank as a child you know when you
have paper routes and Christmas clubs I
would spend it as soon as I busted the
Christmas Club you know like
I would [__] drop it so I was like
it's time to you know I I figured out
how to [__] uh make
600 a week and put away a hundred you
know even though I was a [__] junkie
it was under control and stuff like that
when I got into comedy I really went
back to hand to mouth I mean I don't
know how many times I woke up guys I can
tell you that I woke up
didn't have a [__] dime to get
breakfast not a dime
and I would go well somebody's getting
mugged today I would jump in the shower
brush my teeth Listerine the whole
[__] thing put on clothes and I would
just go out walk into Office Buildings
look for a purse look for a wallet a guy
left a [__] truck uh you know and
went into the store and left the truck
running and left the deposit you have no
idea
about the scenarios that I bumped into I
still remember being [__] flat broke
and Aspen and walking into a supermarket
the shoplift like a [__] like a pack
of [__] uh Oscar Mayer salami you
know how they come in those packages you
can put in your winter jacket and as I
was going to [__] get the salami
a woman a couple was shopping and her
purse was right there and she had her
deposit like the the payment from the
company when you it was sticking out I
remember just walking by and taking the
deposit and putting it in my pocket and
walking out there being like 800 me
envelope going that's a good Payday for
today but there was also a lot of times
when I had to rob a [__] donation box
you know like a [__] little coin
thing I still remember robbing that coin
thing from Carvel and going I'm
definitely going to hell they had some
picture of a kid's Rule and you know and
it's a fake [__] charity but still
you can't run I did all that [__] you
know and uh
being broke [__] sucks the [__]
Christmas that adds even more never mind
the pain you're dry whatever the [__]
but I remember waking up
I always had problems with my ex-wife
like when I was gonna get her for
Christmas you know
the attorney would call and go she's
going to give it to you they're going to
figure out a time and all this so I
wouldn't I really wouldn't know
The Last Christmas I spent in Boulder
they called me like I didn't have a
Christmas Eve that's what it was I was
going to get a Christmas Day
but that didn't tell me to like the 23rd
I had a couple things for her like a
couple little pop-up houses and [__]
like that
and I just wanted to have a good
Christmas and I was like I don't give a
[__] if I go to jail
I'm gonna shoplift every [__] thing
that I can
and I'll never forget on Christmas Eve I
went out in the afternoon
with those last [__] Shoppers and I
shop lifted a bike
far from [__] yeah I'm uh I'm I'm
ashamed of all this [__] but
you know Robin on Christmas being broke
on Christmas is one thing stealing on
Christmas that's not Bueno you got to
say 10 [__] hell Mary's in 19 our
fathers to get that off your [__]
chest
but uh
yeah it was [__] a rough Christmas
and I'll never forget going to Toys R Us
and getting like Puzzles and they would
have Jeffrey money in those days do you
you round for that so I would go in
there and take like a 119 computer
they had these computers by the door and
I wouldn't even walk out of the place
I would pretty much pick up the thing go
through the [__] line they'd give me
140 Jeffrey bucks because they pay your
taxes they give you tax money back and
then I would start from them and then
I'm gonna go in and get something pay
for it legitimately but as I was paying
for it I was also shoplifting something
on the way up so if I paid for a bike I
was taking a box of Legos for 200 on the
way out and then I'd do it again give
them the Legos back get 230 000 Jeffrey
money guys it was embarrassing it was
[__] really embarrassing I must have
put together like a thousand dollars I
had a little apartment like this office
and there was a couch a bench and a TV
everything else was christmased up
and then I was such a [__] puke I'll
never forget coming home
and they called and they're like oh
we're gonna have her there like at a 12
and I'm like 12. I got to get this place
looking like [__] Christmas
and that night I didn't have a Christmas
tree I'll never [__] forget this but
I had uh the [__] you put you know
Garland I had boxes of Garland I must
have shoplifted from somewhere
and I hung it up with duct tape
that's how poor I was I had [__] duct
tape guys
and I just hung it up for [__] duct
tape and then and then my Pierre
resistance Christmas morning I wake up
and I'm like she's gonna be here five
hours I gotta make a [__] Christmas
tree and I was gonna like I started
paper mache in one I didn't know what I
was doing the landlord I asked him if he
had like a little tree from you know he
had a storage area with a bunch of shoes
I got nothing and it was snowing it was
[__] cold miserable and I was on a
search for a [__] Christmas tree
and I drove around for like 20 minutes
and finally as I got closer to my house
because I didn't want to rob a Christmas
tree close to my house and [__] so I was
like I had to rob a Christmas tree
that's I didn't even know I was gonna
rob a Christmas tree I'm like I hope I
can clip a tree from somewhere and
finally I [__] uh
I was flat [__] broke guys maybe 10
bucks in my pocket and I was borrowing
the Deli Zone car those are my friends
that would lent me that car and it had a
thing to keep the door closed the the
bungee cord if I made a [__] left
turn a right turn the door would swing
open and [__] tremendous you can't write
this [__] guys so [__] I uh
I'll never forget I found this Christmas
Place it was right behind the Kmart that
I would shoplift constantly from I had
to give it a breather
but on that day it was Christmas and I'm
like Doug
Kmart was closed every business around
was closed say it was [__] snowing
everything had snow on top of it
and I'll never forget that I I go
there's no Christmas trees there I'm
gonna have to jump that [__] fence it
was like a 10-foot fence get over and
then throw a tree over then load it in
the car how the [__] am I gonna do this
and as I walk closer to the fence it
[__] opened
I'm like how the [__] is defense open on
Christmas
and as I walk closer to the fence as a
sign and it said close Christmas Day
if you see something you like
take it and put your money in the
envelope by the window and I'm like
no they didn't
no they didn't I remember walking in
looking around they had like maybe eight
trees that were like 35 bucks but they
had one tree like for a hundred it was
like a beautiful big tree with frosting
on it it was covered I go that's the
tree I'm [__] taking I picked that
[__] up I put it on the top of
the Toyota I bungee that I didn't care
about the door and then let the door
swing open
and I put the thing and I was looking
for something like glove or an extra
bungee cord and I go hey what about that
envelope where you put the cash in let
me see if there's anything in there
and sure enough it's Christmas I'm broke
and [__] every once in a while God
shines and when I [__] well looked in
the envelope there was like 212 dollars
or something 208 dollars or something
like that something in the two one hour
range I took the whole thing and I even
put in the IOU
and I just signed a Joey
and I [__] took the tree I took the
money I bought some Chinese food
and I went back and that's the last
Christmas I had with my daughter and it
was the best Christmas as broke as I
[__] and was you know that was the
best we [__] opened the Christmas
presents she took a bike on that
Christmas must have cost me 15 I
shoplifted [__] everything clothes
for myself I had like a Christmas robe I
made like cider and [__] it was not good
guys but
that guy sold trees year round and he
did other things in there year round
like he
he saw like Bulldogs or something I
remember I got like a
I got a big [__] check one day
I was just getting ready to leave
Boulder but that Christmas [__]
bothered me me taking that tree and the
cash and [__] I gotta give this guy
something
so I don't know if I got pulling in
there and walking and going hey man I
took a tree from here Christmas and I
didn't uh pay for it but I want to pay
for it today I didn't have the money and
the guy goes man thank you thank you for
[__] being honest I'm not honest I
just certain things bother me and that
really bothered me that day taking it to
an olive tree so I said [__] it I gained
the 200 and my Christmas was [__]
absolved and that time on I really
haven't had a shitty [__] Christmas
they at least been manageable do you
know what I'm saying I mean yeah you
have your moments but then the last 10
Christmases have been great because
I got a daughter and it makes Christmas
more enjoyable at my age
but I tell you A lot of people are going
to be down over the holidays don't let
yourself go down don't let yourself go
down over a [__] holiday that's made
out of love
it's not really a holiday of [__] you
got to show up with a boat or the
biggest present for anybody if you do
that you just fall into the category as
the Joneses I don't give a [__] if you
make a Christmas card you know some of
the best gifts I've had have been
homemade
some of the best gifts I ever had have
been by somebody who said [__] it I'm
not going to spend 10 million [__]
dollars I got a blanket
from a girl a couple years ago and she
made it I still have that blanket in the
[__] basement it's one of the warmest
[__] blankets I have must have cost
you three dollars so don't stress about
the money people like me don't I'm not
looking to [__] kill anybody for
Christmas I really not I could give a
[__] if you give me a DVD or a [__]
pretzel or a bag of weed it all goes to
this I never put
of my wife I've never have so don't feel
[__] ashamed don't feel you know
shitty and if you miss a relative or
something like that amen my mother's
been gone 42 years I still [__] get a
little sentimental around the 23rd the
24th just for a minute just for a minute
it comes and goes and the more holidays
you do the more you will get used to
that
I call a little pain but then it becomes
an inconvenience
just for a minute you might take a
a glass of eggnog or something go holy
[__] this reminds me of my mother [__]
what are you gonna do so
the moral of the story is [__]
don't let the holidays get you down
there's nothing to be down about if you
don't have it you don't have it bring
yourself bring your sense of humor bring
your sweetness and your love and that's
the biggest Christmas present you give
anybody [__] and that's my
podcast for December 1st a beautiful
Thursday morning that's it and that's
that do not forget listen my man uh Todd
dropped from weed off of me from Stoner
Club
I don't know if it's the [__] on the
top or whatever the [__] it's called
go on their website stonerclub.com
they deliver they had a tremendous
[__] uh tremendous [__] sale a ton
of people reached out to me like Joey 25
off Black Friday [__] that's tremendous
yeah oh yeah that hash is [__] great
I finally found the freeze pipe because
free pipe the bubbler gives you a
bubbler
but they also give you an extension
to smoke weed out of it like just
regular like a bowl you know so I
finally got the hash and just because I
was smoking the hash and the big freeze
pipe bung with weed holy [__] but the
problem with that is the [__] hash
keeps burning it keeps burnishing she
got keep taking [__] hits and you end
up [__] being all stolen robots and
[__] like that but yeah everything's
going great remember when you order from
Stoners Club Preston Uncle Joey and get
10 off for Life how's that one for you
[__] that's how I [__] roll
and that's it I'll put an ad up for the
link on the book this week
we're taking all this December [__]
uh 31st
my next show is the 28th I might pop
around town I seen Russell uh Russell
Peters is in [__] njpac I think
Saturday night I got a [__] uh Hollis
Gracie's doing that yearly Jiu Jitsu
party I'm excited about that I was gonna
go to a [__] hockey game but my
daughter has a basketball game at six
and I'll never make it to the devil's
[__] uh
Philly Flyer game so what are you gonna
do man you can't do it all you can just
treat it try to be the best and make the
best of it guys I love you [__]
with all my heart December's here stay
[__] beautiful I'll see you
[__] Monday morning Tip Top
Magoo and now for a word for my
[__] sponsors Jack
all right you bad [__] I want
to thank yous all for listening this
week and for being here with me the
joint is brought to you by CBD lion
listen this is the time of the year to
get ready for 2023. you're not getting a
line for today you're gonna start this
new tincture program next year and feel
better about yourself but go to
cbdlions.com and read the third party
lab results and they're going to knock
you into the [__] Moon whether you're
looking for a tincture a cream for your
knee or your shoulder a kinesiology tape
for your back or back ball that you
throw in with hot water oh my God you'll
feel Tip Top Magoo the next day CBD lion
call Joey and joy
and get 20 [__] percent off today
right that's how easy this is get ready
for 2023 the joint is also brought to
you by
stamps.com listen it's never too late to
get your holiday mailing and shipping
under control with stamps.com sign up
now and you'll be printing your own
postage in minutes use stamps.com to
print postage whenever you do business
all you need is a computer and a printer
with stamps.com you can easily schedule
pickup and compare carriers and rates
with the click of the button and if
you're running an online store
stamps.com Works seamlessly with all
major shopping carts and marketplaces
this holiday season trade in the late
nights for silent nights Jack and get
started with stamps.com today sign up
with promo code Joey j-o-e-y for a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial free postage and a free digital
scale no long-term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com click on
the microphone and enter code Joey I
want to thank stamps.com I want to thank
manscape I want to thank CBD line I want
to thank better help and I want to thank
heart and soul but most importantly I
want to thank you savages for another
great week man I love you stay black and
I'll be back Monday morning Tip Top
Magoo
all right